we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p this
voicemail is a reminder about why uh
what is there is a reminder of many
things this is a reminder about why
we're not going to win by arguing with
trumpets okay let me just leave it at
that and we'll listen to it you're
watching destroy me page for inquiries
and i because i don't understand nothing
I was a Democrat now I'm a Republican
because of the way the Democrats have
acted and done to this country taking
money from Social Security and
everything else and y'all have been
after President Trump ever since he
became president and I think it's a
shame it's pitiful have a good day yeah
so that's why just arguing with people
and trying to convince folks like that
it just can't be a strategy and we have
sort of a follow-up voicemail to that
coming up on tomorrow's program that I
think you will also find equally
disturbing if you are concerned with the
truth and facts and understanding things
as they are rather than as you would
wish them to be but that's a perfect
example of why we just need to get the
vote out and convincing people like that
to change their mind it's not going to
happen alright we've got a great bonus
show coming up for you we will talk
about the four women Joe Biden says he
would consider as running mates we will
talk about the struggles of the milk
industry we will talk about Tesla's new
cyber truck and I will disclose share
ownership now I'm not doing that anymore
but I do and of course remember that on
Black Friday we will have a huge David
Pakman show membership special to be
notified of that just become a
subscriber to the newsletter by signing
up at david pakman.com and on black
friday you will have that very exciting
membership discount code in your email
i'll speak to you on the bonus show in
just a minute